you're in - fantastic beloved
oscar-nominated films so exciting and
what's what's interesting is that you
had this totally other career you know
beforehand which you'll continue to have
but you're an amazing singer and
performer thank you I'm just curious
when did you know that you were a singer
is that one of those things that you
knew early was there and was there a
time when you were a kid where you just
you just declared I'm a singer oh yes
when I was probably five or I don't even
know how old I was but my I used to take
me to church with her and there was a
moment where our pastor was just so in
you know the spirit and felt the Holy
Spirit I had everybody come and get a
blessing and then it got like quiet for
a little bit he was wiping his forehead
and I just remember saying just beat my
mouth shoot and I just remember
everybody in the church choir just
laughing yeah and I knew just like I'm
gonna sing something I want to sing Mike
and that's yeah very appropriate yeah
you